merci d'être avec nous Valérie Boyer et
de nous accompagner pendant cette
première demi-heure élu des
bouches-du-roulement du groupe les
républicains on a beaucoup d'actualités
à voir avec vous on va parler de
l'Arménie dans quelques instants mais
d'abord la Pologne vous présidez ici au
Sénat le groupe d'amitié France Pologne
on a vu cette information à missile qui
a donc touché la Pologne missile
d'origine indéterminée la France appelle
à la plus grande prudence sur l'origine
de ce tir comment réagissez-vous je
pense que il faut effectivement être
prudent toutes ces informations sont
inquiétantes et une chose est certaine
une ligne se dessine c'est que personne
n'a envie de l'escalade y compris la
Russie je pense que la Russie
aujourd'hui qui subit un revers
supplémentaire mais un revers quand même
très cuisant avec kiersen n'a pas envie
il n'a pas les moyens d'avoir un nouveau
front d'autant que sur la scène
internationale elle est quand même
lâchée
sur le plan militaire par ces alliés et
puis qu'elle est en train de perdre tous
les pays choisi centrale donc
l'hypothèse d'un tir volontaire de la
part de la Russie j'en sais rien je ne
sais pas si on connaîtra la vérité
d'ailleurs mais
voilà aujourd'hui on sait qu'en Ukraine
il y a beaucoup de matériel soviétique
soit qui était sur place soit qui a été
récupéré en grande quantité une
erreur est toujours possible plusieurs
choses sont possibles et sans probables
je crois qu'aujourd'hui ce qui compte
c'est pas d'escalade vous savez c'est
pas la première fois qu'un pays de
l'OTAN
est visé je rappelle qu'il y a deux ans
c'était la Grèce qui était visée par la
Turquie et c'est la France qui est venu
au secours de la Grèce avec des
manœuvres en Méditerranée orientale que
depuis 1974 la Turquie occupe Chypre de
façon militaire que ça n'a pas empêché
alia verdogan de de fêter
de façon particulièrement indécente mais
leur victoire sur les Arméniens sur la
44 jours en 2020 à varocha c'est à dire
en zone de notre chibriotes en tant que
personne ne bronche donc voilà
aujourd'hui je pense que dans ce conflit
particulièrement difficile
nul sur cette planète n'a envie d'un
embrasement vous demandez à Nanterre
vous demandez Élisabeth borde de
s'exprimer sur la situation et sur ce
que fait la France sur le suivi de cette
situation en Pologne
toute façon elle sera elle sera
interrogée
mais il y a aucun doute sur le fait que
nous sommes près de nos amis polonais ça
c'est une évidence qui sont en première
ligne qui ont accueilli des milliers de
réfugiés même des millions de réfugiés
Ukrainiens qu'ils avaient déjà en grand
nombre sur leur territoire qui était des
travailleurs
et qui sont absolument remarquables
exemplaires dans ce conflit et je pense
que ça c'est à souligner et d'ailleurs
l'Union européenne devrait
le souligner également
vous revenez des États-Unis entre sujet
pour revenir tout juste des Etats-Unis
vous étiez là-bas comme observatrice
lors des élections de mi-mandat alors
oui membres de l'OSCE quel était votre
rôle et qu'avez-vous constaté alors le
rôle de l'Assemblée parlementaire de
l'OSCE c'est d'aller observer les
élections et des roulements de la
démocratie or c'est vrai que la semaine
dernière la plus grande démocratie du
monde votait mais le système électoral
américain il est extrêmement différent
d'une autre d'abord parce que on vote
nous on parle des termes c'est à dire on
parle de des assemblées américaines mais
avec des élections tous les quatre ans
et demi mandats pour des élections
présidentielles tous les quatre ans et
des mimandats tous les quatre ans
c'est-à-dire au milieu du mandat
présidentiel pour le Parlement pour les
Parlement donc
c'est déjà très compliqué donc ça veut
dire qu'on est en élection permanente en
campagne permanente et on vote aux
États-Unis pour les maires pour les
juges pour donc on a effectivement
un système électoral avec un bulletin
électoral qui est à peu près cette
taille et je où il faut cocher de
multiples cases donc déjà ça ça rend le
scrutin extrêmement compliqué
et le constat qui a été fait c'est
qu'effectivement on a le sentiment que
même si Joe Biden a annoncé sa
candidature il y a quelques semaines et
que Donald Trump lui emboîte le pas que
c'est un petit peu enfin ça semble être
la fin du Der parce qu'effectivement des
deux côtés les candidats à un moment
donné je crois que
le temps fait son ouvrage et que on peut
lutter sur beaucoup de choses mais pas
sur cette réalité biologique
donc on ne sait pas ce qu'il en sera
mais il est certain que si
Donald Trump se présente Biden va dire
bah moi aussi après tout on n'a pas trop
de différence d'âge quoi qu'ils ont
quatre ans de différence d'âge et puis
je l'ai déjà battu une fois donc je peux
le battre une deuxième fois donc bon
chacun se tient par la barbichette il
fut m'exprimer ainsi dans cette affaire
qui fait sourire mais qui est quand même
sérieuse parce que la plus grande
démocratie du monde
voilà peut être incarné par des
personnes qui sont quand même
fatigué quoi qu'on puisse en dire peu de
beaucoup de points et puis sur le plan
plus politique il est certain que Ron De
Santis qui est le celui qui semblerait
succéder pour pour les pour les
conservateurs pour les républicains à
Donald Trump lui enregistré beaucoup de
succès tandis que les candidats Donald
Trump ont été mis en difficulté et
d'ailleurs le succès escompté n'est pas
arrivé puisque les résultats du Sénat le
Sénat reste à une voix près donc chez
les démocrates on va parler de l'Arménie
puisque le Sénat a voté hier une
résolution pour condamner les
agissements de l'Azerbaïdjan vers
l'Arménie on va voir d'abord les temps
forts de cette séance avec six jours
dans
on y va on y va sans jingle
a les yeux rivés sur l'Ukraine on en
parlait mais pendant ce temps là le
Sénat garde également un oeil à l'Est
car le conflit se poursuit entre les
Azerbaïdjan et l'armée oui un conflit
peut-être moins spectaculaire mais qui
semble interminable et qui fait des
morts en septembre
286 combattants ou un nouveau été tués
lors de heure très violents il s'agit du
plus lourd bilan depuis 2020 et la
guerre autour du ok rabat on va voir une
carte pour bien comprendre le haut
Caraba c'est cette région peuplée en
majorité d'Arméniens et qui a rompu ses
liens avec l'Azerbaïdjan dans les années
90 César baïdjan considère que cette
zone lui appartint la lui appartient la
situation reste donc explosive à la
frontière entre les deux pays et le
Sénat veut inciter le gouvernement à
freiner les ambitions de laserbaïdjan
une proposition de résolution trans
partisane a donc été adoptée en ce sens
hier une résolution ça n'a pas de valeur
contraignante ça n'a pas de valeur
législative ça ça sert simplement à
attirer l'attention du gouvernement et
des médias sur une préoccupation mais
notez que le texte a été signé par
plusieurs présidents de groupe c'est
donc qu'il fait largement consensus ici
au Sénat en l'occurrence la chambre
haute demande je cite le retrait des
troupes azerbaïdjanaises sur leur
position initiale notamment en dehors du
territoire arménien et du couloir de la
Chine il s'agit en fait de faire
respecter un cesser le feu signé entre
les deux pays en 2020 lors de la
précédente guerre avec une carte c'est
toujours plus facile on va la voir le
cessez-le-feu de 2020 prévoyez une libre
circulation entre l'Arménie et le haut
Caraba via notamment le corridor de la
Chine que vous voyez c'est en rouge la
petite bande en rouge le Sénat demande
un retour au terme du cessez-le-feu mais
aussi des sanctions contre laserbaïdi
j'aurais écouté Bruno Retailleau le
patron du groupe LR
le temps n'est plus à observer il est
désormais à décider le temps n'est plus
à protester il est à sanctionner c'est
précisément ce que propose cette
résolution il y a eu des crimes de
guerre en Ukraine il y en a aussi en
harmonie et à nouveau alors que dans un
cas ces crimes sont poursuivis en
Arménie rien ne se passe ce deux poids
de mesure mes chers collègues c'est une
véritable honte Valérie Boyer des
sanctions contre laserbaïdjan à quoi ça
pourrait ressembler écoutez déjà je
pense qu'il faut remercier le Sénat
d'être constant dans ses engagements
puisque c'est en n'oubliant pas que le
25 novembre 2020 c'est au Sénat qu'il y
a eu cette résolution pour reconnaître
l'arc Sark alors qu'elle était attaquée
de façon totalement asymétrique et
injuste par laserbaïdjan qui est attaqué
donc cette zone que voyant en rouge qui
est arménienne
d'ailleurs je rappelle parce que on voit
la carte l'envoie la mer Caspienne donc
on voit bas coût l'Arménie avant était
appelée le royaume des trois mères donc
mer Méditerranée mer Caspienne et voilà
et aujourd'hui enfin depuis que Staline
avait fait en sorte que des minorités
soient isolées etc pour pour pouvoir
mieux des contraintes et après la chute
du mur il y a eu cette guerre qui a été
gagnée par les Arméniens pour retrouver
leur territoire par rapport à
l'Azerbaïdjan or en septembre 2020
l'Azerbaïdjan a attaqué le Karaba dans
une guerre d'une violence inouïe avec
des armes à avec des armes interdites
des fragmentations des bombophosphore à
retenue des prisonniers qu'elle a
torturé etc dans l'indifférence totale
seul le Sénat a réagi et puis après
suivi par l'Assemblée nationale et au
moment où on interrogé le ministre des
Affaires étrangères à l'époque Jean-Yves
Le Drian il nous disait neutralité
neutralité parce que la France la partie
prenante aux accords de mix qui
réunissaient Russie États-Unis et France
justement pour parler de ce conflit gelé
aujourd'hui deux ans après alors que des
prisonniers Arméniens ne sont toujours
pas restitués ou quand ils sont
restitués on voit qu'ils ont été
torturés maltraités etc l'état corrompu
raciste de d'Azerbaïdjan parce que c'est
quand même de ça dont il s'agit attaque
non pas ce territoire en rouge mais
l'Arménie que l'on voit ici qui est un
pays avec des frontières reconnues par
la communauté internationale qui est une
démocratie et l'attaque pour pourquoi
parce que
l'Azerbaïdjan comme la Turquie sont
complices membres de l'OTAN veut
exterminer ce qu'ils appellent les
restes de l'épée c'est à dire les
Arméniens les restes de l'épée ça fait
référence au conflit enfin à au génocide
de 1915 et à lièvre dit qu'il veut
chasser ses chiens d'Arméniens donc on
est vraiment dans une guerre raciste
génocidaire pour exterminer Arménie et
j'en termine par là pour plein de
raisons dont une qui est majeure qui est
le délire panturkistes d'Erdogan que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure pour Chypre et
la Grèce mais qui s'attaque aussi à
l'Égypte etc et qui a des prétentions
jusqu'aux Maroc ce que l'Empire ottoman
n'a jamais été jusque là mais bon c'est
quand même dans le dans le délire
d'Erdogan il va jusque là mais il en a
un autre vers l'est c'est à dire qu'il
veut faire en sorte que l'Arménie voyez
Turquie Azerbaïdjan hop il veut que le
turquois que le couloir turcophone et
malheureusement l'Arménie est placé au
milieu
aille jusqu'à bifteck c'est à dire
jusqu'au Kirghistan jusqu'au frontières
de la Chine jusqu'au ouigo même si on
peut pas dire qu'il est défendu les
Ouigours contre les Chinois c'est très
intéressant
je dis ça parce que la France
aujourd'hui doit cesser sa position de
neutralité ou d'observation on en est
plus aux observations ce que la France a
fait pour le Mali pourquoi elle ne le
fait pas pour l'Arménie que l'Union
européenne fait pour l'Ukraine pourquoi
elle ne le fait pas pour l'Arménie
vaut-elle moins que celle des Ukrainiens
c'est la question qu'on peut se poser
aujourd'hui pourquoi pour plein de
raisons
mais moi je quand même je note et je
l'ai dit à la tribune du Sénat une
nouvelle fois que Madame Ursula
vanderlione s'est rendu à Bakou j'allais
dire toute honte bu pour signer un
contrat gazier avec l'Azerbaïdjan cet
été en disant kerdogan en lui serrant la
main etc l'embrassant comme du bon pain
était analié sur et fiable cet accord
est indécent
d'autant que l'on sait que la
laserbaïdjan exporte plus de gaz qu'elle
n'en produit pourquoi pour une raison
bien simple c'est que l'Azerbaïdjan il a
réussi ont toujours eu des liens très
forts même si depuis des années il se
rapproche plus de la Turquie que de la
Russie
et que bien évidemment une gaz russe que
Madame Van derlenian est allé acheter
est-ce qu'on a les moyens de faire
autrement avec le robinet rue on a les
moyens
on ne peut pas avoir deux poids de
mesure et tenir ce type de langage ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui en Arménie et
d'une gravité extrême on peut peut-être
assister à la mort d'un pays avec une
poursuite génocidaire qui n'est pas du
tout caché ni par la Turquie ni par
l'Azerbaïdjan c'est le premier point le
deuxième point si les Français qui nous
écoutent pensent une seconde que les
Turcs et les azéries vont s'arrêter à
l'Arménie je pense qu'il se trompe
totalement
Erdogan et son ami alief n'ont pas caché
leur dessin sur la Grèce et sur Chypre
et même sur l'Égypte qu'ils essayent de
déstabiliser et l'attentat qui a eu
récemment en Turquie soi-disant des
Kurdes commis un attentat bon on a bien
vu les manipulations d'Erdogan du vice
qui a une chose
c'est porter un coup fatal au kurde
encore une fois c'est pour avoir des
choses
moi ce que je souhaiterais c'est que un
on soit clair que l'Union européenne
s'engage et les États-Unis aussi
auprès des Arméniens à quoi ça sert de
faire en sorte que la journée du 24
avril 1915 soit reconnu comme une
journée de commémoration nationale
française si ce n'est pour tourner la
tête quand il se passe des choses
des uns pour l'Arménie des hommes pour
l'Arménie pourquoi on n'envoie pas des
forces interposition puisque les Russes
ne sont pas en mesure l'ont-ils été
d'ailleurs d'assurer la sécurité de
l'Arménie qui n'avait que pour seul
allié et amis entre guillemets la Russie
effectivement qui a arrêté la la
progression de l'Azerbaïdjan en
septembre 2020 mais aujourd'hui le
conflit
ukrainienne et les échecs répétitifs
essuyés par la Russie font que la Russie
clairement n'a pas rempli ses objectifs
de protection pour l'Arménie vous savez
hier ou avant-hier s'est déroulé en
Arménie un exercice assez inédit c'est à
dire que les Arméniens d'Arméniens ont
été appelés à faire des exercices pour
se protéger en cas d'attaque aérienne
quand on est là dans un pays quand vous
avez plus de 50 km² d'un territoire
souverain qui est occupé par une armée
admie qui torture qui terrorise qui
violent qui commet des crimes de guerre
qui est tellement fière en plus de ces
exactions
et bien ça veut dire que l'Arménie est
vraiment en grand danger aujourd'hui
donc effectivement le Sénat c'est un cri
d'alerte poussé aux autorités françaises
pour qu'elles agissent enfin hier Bruno
Retailleau l'a fait remarquer je l'ai
souligné et d'autres collègues de tous
les groupes l'ont fait souligner c'était
quand même indécent d'envoyer à la
chambre à la Haute Assemblée un
secrétaire d'État au Commerce extérieur
pour écouter ce que nous allions faire
en tant que représentant du gouvernement
alors j'ai rien contre les compétences
de de ce ministre j'ai oublié le nom
d'ailleurs mais voilà mais franchement
c'était pas la hauteur des enjeux alors
que la France prétend être une amie pour
l'Arménie alors que la France à cette
journée nationale alors que la France
dit qu'elle est une sorte pour l'Arménie
aujourd'hui la situation est extrêmement
grave pour ce pays je veux dire on n'est
plus au conflit je l'ai on est sur la
république souveraine et démocratique
d'Arménie qui est une vraie démocratie
contrairement aux pays qui l'entourent
merci Steve à tout à l'heure de la faire
Hanouna et de ses suites c'est
prolongations au Sénat exactement avec
notamment un autre texte qui a été voté
hier sur la protection des élus merci
beaucoup
à tout à l'heure c'est pas la même non
c'est pas la même chose mais
effectivement ça fait partie de la
violence en politique on débattra
effectivement de ce thème tout à l'heure
on va aller chez vous à Marseille
retrouvez-les au purgate président et
directeur éditorial de la Marseillaise
bonjour Léo merci d'être avec nous dans
la Marseillaise vous revenez sur la
nomination de Christophe Castaner au
grand port de Marseille
oui tout à fait marcheur historique
ministre de l'Intérieur qui a fait
parler de lui pour la répression du
mouvement social selon nos informations
alors que Stéphane Richard tenait la
corde à un moment et il devrait être élu
bientôt à la tête du Grand port maritime
de Marseille Valérie Boyer vous vous
connaissez évidemment bien cette
institution est-ce que c'est un recazage
ou est-ce que c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour ce territoire je pense que la
réponse est à votre question moi je note
quand même que Emmanuel Macron n'est pas
avare de recazage pour tout pour tous
ses amis
qui n'oublie pas sur le bord du chemin y
compris quand ceci sont été sortis par
les électeurs et par leurs échecs quand
même cuisant donc effectivement en
macronie plus c'est gros plus ça passe
vous savez que cette nomination
Christophe Castaner par le ministre par
le pardon par Emmanuel Macron succède à
celle du directeur du Mucem qui a été
nommé pour ses grandes compétences qui
est notamment d'être un ami de Madame
Macron et d'avoir travaillé auprès de
Brigitte Macron donc
voilà la compétence qui a été requise
pour le Christ parce que là il
de surveillance il y aura l'élection
pour le président ce sera la semaine
prochaine ou vous souhaitez que ce ne
soit pas lui qui remporte cette élection
écoutez moi je veux pas membres
je ne veux pas mais franchement le
recazage des amis d'Emmanuel Macron des
copains d'Emmanuel Macron s'il tentait
même s'ils ont été ministre et on sait
qu'elle a été le succès de Christophe
Castaner comme ministre je crois que
personne ne l'a oublié bah c'est pas une
bonne nouvelle pour Marseille parce que
on fait jouer plus les relations et le
copinage que la compétence et je ne vois
pas quelle est la compétence de
Christophe Castaner dans ce poste là
tout à fait clairement c'est assez
méprisant vous savez à Marseille on
attendait le grand Marseille et on a
Christophe Castaner donc c'est un peu
triste également à lire dans La
Marseillaise un dossier sur les pénuries
alimentaires et plus précisément sur la
pénurie 2
absolument les œufs après la moutarde la
farine les pâtes voilà leur prix explosé
il y a même désormais des ruptures
d'approvisionnement dans les
supermarchés alors même que les Français
confrontés aux difficultés de
l'inflation c'était reporter parfois
plutôt que d'acheter de la viande ou des
poissons sur les œufs on interroge des
éleveurs qui nous explique leur
difficulté ce que je voulais demander à
Valérie Boyer c'est et bien quels sont
vos solutions à LR sur la question du
pouvoir d'achat on sait que votre partie
cherche à renouer avec un certain
électorat populaire quels sont les
réponses que vous leur apportez
vous savez la question du pouvoir
d'achat a toujours été une préoccupation
extrêmement importante de notre partie
et je dois dire que nous préférons la
baisse des impôts plutôt que l'échec qui
sont distribués au parcours on l'a vu
pour l'instant on propose nous une
baisse des taxes sur les sens en
attendant de trouver d'autres solutions
d'énergie plus verte voilà on propose
toute une série de mesures mais on voit
bien que sous Emmanuel Macron jamais les
prélèvements n'ont été aussi importants
et la dette explose parallèlement donc
effectivement là aussi on a un échec de
la politique à la fois j'allais dire
social et économique du pays puisqu'elle
se cumule avec un déficit du commerce
extérieur qui est totalement inédit
alors que notre voisin allemand lui
enregistre un excédent donc on est
vraiment dans une nasse et tout à
l'heure on évoquait le conflit en
Arménie vous allez me dire il y a pas
beaucoup de rapport avec les œufs
il y en a un c'est que quand on est
endetté à la hauteur qui est la nôtre et
bien on a plus notre souveraineté et on
est en train de perdre notre
souveraineté en général et notre
souveraineté alimentaire aussi et ça
c'est une préoccupation majeure que le
gouvernement devrait prendre abras le
corps et j'ai pas tellement l'impression
que ce soit le cas aujourd'hui
merci léopurgate on regarde la une c'est
la Pologne jeu de dus pour réel
engrenage Léo
oui on appelle on appelle évidemment une
désescalade dans l'édito d'aujourd'hui
halte au feu parce que en effet la
situation est extrêmement inflammable et
aucun peuple aucun peuple sur la planète
n'a intérêt à cet escalade merci Léo
c'est-à-dire dans la Marseillaise votre
une de dus pour elle engrenage c'est la
question effectivement on en parlait au
début de cette interview Valley on va
parler DLR pour terminer vous êtes l'une
des racines à soutenir
des sénateurs qui sont plutôt du côté de
Bruno Retailleau pourquoi ce choix c'est
un choix d'abord qui est ancien pour
Éric Ciotti et puis c'est aussi un choix
de la proximité de l'amitié de
Erik sottier quelqu'un de courageux
d'engager qui a fait un score
aux personnes ne l'attendait pour
l'élection interne pour la
présidentielle
[Musique]
donc aujourd'hui de toute façon on est
dans une situation où
la fin de la macronie ça a été le soir
de la réélection d'Emmanuel Macron
puisqu'il ne peut pas se représenter
donc on sait très bien que il nous faut
trouver une solution et aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas être enfermé dans le choix
qu'Emmanuel Macron a imposé aux Français
c'est-à-dire soit Jean-Luc Mélenchon
soit Marine Le Pen et effectivement les
députés et les sénateurs les
républicains incarne je le pense une
espérance et pour que cette espérance
soit incarnée il faut qu'on ait un parti
qui fonctionne avec des élus qui soient
solidaires qui proposent des solutions
aux Français on vient de l'évoquer sur
le pouvoir d'achat on vient de l'évoquer
sur la situation internationale
notamment sur l'Arménie c'est quand même
notre famille politique qui a eu la main
et donc je pense qu'il faut poursuivre
dans ce sens là et un dernier mot sur X
ce type puisque le canard enchaînait
selon le Canard Enchaîné Éric Ciotti son
ancienne épouse aurait cumulé plusieurs
emplois lorsqu'elle était sa
collaboratrice à temps partiel à
l'Assemblée nationale elle aurait été
employée au conseil départemental
Alpes-Maritimes qui dirigeait à l'époque
et au cabinet du maire de Nice Christian
Estrosi alors qui dit que ses emplois
ont été occupés successivement et que
cela n'a jamais dépassé le cumul horaire
autorisé comment réagissez-vous à ce que
dit moi je fais confiance à Éric sotti
et j'avoue que je suis fatigué de ces
attaques perpétuelles pour discréditer
nos candidats c'est quelque chose qui me
semble très malsain pour la démocratie
au moment où on passe par exemple sous
silence des choses extrêmement
importantes et stratégiques comme Alstom
comme technique dans lesquelles le
gouvernement est engagé tout à l'heure
on évoquait les nominations des amis de
Brigitte Macron ou d'Emmanuel Macron a
des postes clés je suis désolé ces
questions sont bien plus importantes et
sont déterminantes aussi pour notre pays
parlons-en parce que où on en est de la
transparence de la vie publique quand on
est amené à constater ce type j'allais
dire sont pas des décisions mais
d'imposition merci Valérie Boyer merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité 20
minutes dans le cas de territoire on
parlera de la violence envers les élus
notamment de ce texte voté hier au Sénat
pour renforcer leur protection et
d'abord on va accueillir Olivier Marleix
qui nous rejoint